foreign
so John we um we were talking before we
got on the air and I think it's worth
just carrying that conversation forward
a little bit there is a uh uh there
seems to be a movement or a stirring and
I don't I don't think it's coordinated I
think it's just observation by several
people who are good critical thinkers
there's an observation by people like uh
Michael Easter who wrote the book
Comfort crisis uh by
um some of our friends over the daily
wire uh by
um uh people like Mike Rowe our friend
micro uh this there is the seems to be a
separation in our culture right now and
a recognition of this like never before
between the
people who are willing to
work
and sacrifice and have mental or
physical calluses
calluses on your mind because you push
through you persevere through something
stressful on your hands literally
because you're doing like real work
um
versus
quiet quitting versus I'm going to work
from home
which means I don't work much
I'm not really working from home uh
there's pretty much two categories of
people all the data is starting to show
us people that work from home there are
those that work way too much
like become Workaholics at home they
don't quit they get up from dinner
abandon their kids go back to their
screen and keep working all night and
then there are those that work like two
hours a day and call that a full-time
job and play with their children in the
middle of the floor while they're
supposed to be working but there's this
group of people that are uh bent on
mediocrity they're bent on doing as
little as possible they are bent on just
getting by they are bent on trying to
quote cheat the system and someone else
take care of them and then there's this
group of people
that are kind of I guess old school that
are working that have work ethic that
are leaning in and they can be of any
age group it is not a a generational
thing I saw somebody today railing on
gen Z it's not gen z uh because I'm
meeting Boomers that are doing these
exact same crap one way or the other but
in a in a culture where uh a percent a
an unusually large percentage has
decided to do little or nothing if
you're willing to do a lot you're going
to stand out oh man you got chance for
Success like never before in our world
right I I I I go all the way back to
I I actually and maybe I'm crazy I or
I'm overly optimistic my wife says
sometimes I I think we got here with
good intentions back in the I mean you
remember back in the 70s and 80s
there are some studies done that showed
man these folks who are are CEOs and
leaders they've got good self-esteem
and so what we need to give these kids
in elementary school is we just need to
tell them how great they are all the
time so they have good self-esteem and
what we missed and then we the
participation trophy was born that's
right everybody's gonna feel good about
themselves and then they'll all become
like that and what we missed is no they
became like that because they failed a
lot and they got hit in the mouth a lot
and they kept persevering and they had
people around them that walked alongside
them similarly man we everyone I just
put a thing on Instagram everyone wants
to win the Super Bowl but nobody wants
to get tackled by a 350 pound man yeah
and that's that's Tom Brady got hit a
whole bunch yeah right it's like like
his lineman got hit way more it's not
getting hit by a Kia I mean really I
mean it's just but but I want to win the
Super Bowl but I don't I don't want any
dirt under my fingernails and I don't
want to hear my joints Creak I think
it's the old Bobby Knight quote everyone
everyone wants to be win the
championship
nobody wants to practice real hard right
and you don't put that time in and I
think we have a culture of folks who
Miss they don't have a picture of what
that Gap looks like and now I actually
think it sounds old school but I'm
seeing it in the Medical Science and in
the mental health science it's a new
wave of people coming in saying
oh our bodies can't exist without stress
and tension it can't exist without
having something to push up against you
don't go to the gym and lift a ribbon
you got to put weight on that bar
otherwise your body never grows you
don't get stronger and so we I think we
have to teach a whole generation of
people
here's how to get back up you know what
part of it is too I mean you used to get
dopamine hits from stress and from
leaning into something oh dude lifting
this participation now now you get
dopamine hit from everywhere from well
this magic wand in your hand oh dude yes
you got a magic wand in your hand that
gives your dopamine hits all day long
that aren't from but there's no real
stress associated with it and so there's
this atrophying of character right that
has occurred and I I used to tell my
students
when Martin was marching across the
bridge Dr King the Assumption was you're
gonna get killed doing this and we're
going anyway that's different than the
the thumb Warriors I call them like like
launching their grenades via social
media like there's this lack of hey dude
if you're gonna get in the arena you're
gonna get hurt and that's that's part of
the whole game not you can't see on the
outside of the arena and pretend you
participated right you got to get in
there and that means you're gonna get
knocked down and if there is no
toughness there is no perseverance if
there's no calluses there is no
perseverance and if there is no
perseverance there is no success and
then the self-esteem not not the
self-esteem and then and what you can't
do Dave you can't lie to your body you
can tell yourself you're the toughest
guy in that room you can tell yourself I
could do it I could do it your body
knows we're not ready for this and it's
fluffy there's a yeah there's a gap
right it's like oh I could do that your
body's telling you I don't think we can
man and I'm like we can don't do that
don't do it and so man get some true
real experiences underneath your belt
um yeah so when in doubt bust up into
something yes when in doubt overdo it
yes but when in doubt activity not
passive right right
um we have a culture that's overthinking
everything get out and start doing man
gotta start doing a fail and quit trying
to figure out the uh the macro economic
uh Marxist angle on something yeah good
job dude yeah just just go work
what's that line your grandma had I
loved there's a great place to go when
you're broke to work you know I mean
that's just that that but that's that's
old school right there and here's the
thing it's also new school because
really there is no success without it
right there is no success in your
marriage unless you're intentional and
you work at it that sounds very romantic
every day but you got to you know when I
got married I did you know I didn't know
beans I've read like 100 marriage books
I think you know I started raising kids
I I don't know what I was doing I
started reading parenting books you know
I there's it without doing it on purpose
without some lifting without some stress
without some push which always involves
a calluses developing
um there is no success so there's no
strength there's no growth looking for
uh the Amazon Prime for your life take
the hard pack you can push a button and
crap shows up on your Port take the hard
pass okay that's not how life really
works if you've been trained by this
magic wand in your hand to not lean into
the strenuous activities uh take that
thing and drop your heel down on it and
crush it and go lean into some strenuous
activities this is where the best parts
of life come from